Oh
[Music]
it's time for afternoon prayers and the
Muslim inmates in this California state
prison are doing what was once forbidden
having an Islamic worship service people
couldn't gather in groups to teach and
do practices of religion of the 3832
inmates at Solano prison the chaplain
estimates about five percent are
practicing Muslims the prison doesn't
track religious identity partly because
it's so fluid and religious expression
is a barometer for how Islam has evolved
within the US penitentiary system hey
guys I'm Shireen and today we've
travelled to Solano prison in Vacaville
California to explore how the world's
fastest-growing religion has had to
fight to find a home in prison
[Music]
when I became Muslim I was given a set
of principles do this don't do that when
in doubt don't that's Jessie Burleson
who people here know as Hasani he's been
in prison for 31 years
Hasani is one of the practicing Muslims
at Solano prison and they're part of the
millions of people behind bars in the
u.s. in fact the United States has the
largest prison population in the world
the more than 2.3 million people it had
incarcerated by the end of 2017 were
more than any other developed nation
that number includes inmates at federal
state and county prisons and it's
growing in a place where you're housing
meals and recreation time is highly
constrained by rules finding a way to
practice your faith can be difficult
these inmates have figured out a way to
infuse their faith into their sentences
one of the things that started me
seeking something different was I was
looking at the people that were around
me
who were older than I was who had been
in prison longer than me and who had
been on that same negative
self-destructive path and me not being
satisfied with what I was seeing in them
and at that time I started going to
religious services it didn't matter if
it was Muslim Christian Jewish I went
seeking a better way and I believed in
God so I know that the only way I was
gonna change was through God he's just
one of the Muslims that solano chaplain
Muhammad Ali interacts with on a daily
basis Ali is an imam who spent four
years at this prison helping people like
Hassan II explore their faith he
believes it can be an important part of
their rehabilitation religion is
important to inmates because it connects
them to something bigger than their
their circumstance you have people who
you know where you're here in prison and
there's a lot of things you can't
control whether
sure you're eating with it's your living
condition
it really helps human beings feel
essence of connectedness to something
beyond what's what's right in front of
them but as long as journey and
Penitentiary's has been complicated by
prison culture and legal challenges
though nationally Muslims make up 1% of
the US population that number is
expected to double by 2050 some of that
growth specifically comes from inmates
converting to Islam behind bars Islam is
known for having a particularly strong
presence in prisons in fact more people
convert to Islam per capita than any
other religion nationwide Muslims make
up 10 to 15% of prisoners Ali even said
he has one to two inmates convert to
Islam monthly so that's not his goal
what makes those statistics resonate
more is knowing how difficult it was to
get Islam accepted as a recognized
religion within some prisons the prison
administration through their custody
officers wouldn't allow groups of
Muslims that congregate over three and
when they did they would break they
would break them up that's Abdul Rauf
Nasir and he spent 30 years using his
Islamic faith to help inmates and
correctional institutions he considered
it social justice work and an active
part of his faith back when he started
in the 1970s he says the prison system
was full of subtle discrimination
against Muslims some Muslim inmates at
this prison sued in 1996 for greater
access to religious services their
demands included hiring a full-time
Muslim chaplain and the ability to
attend Friday prayers without penalties
like demerits for leaving work
eventually they did receive a full-time
Imam and their other demands prison
officials dispute this account they say
Muslim inmates were never denied access
to their religion and instead the
constraints were reflective of staffing
and organizational issues that were
resolved nationwide the legal pushes
continue today the 2013 report says that
Muslims submitted the most religious
discrimination complaints out of any
other religious group in prison Islam
and Muslim
organizations in prisons for the most
part seem to be powerful because they've
been there a long time they have
challenged the status quo of the prison
system itself legally and physically
that quality of questioning power is
easily identifiable with one of the
religions most notable converts Malcolm
X his narrative is prominent and so that
attracts people toward Islam and then
the reformative value that they find in
that the hope that it gives that I can
survive in prison
Malcolm survived in prison Malcolm X's
legacy still resonates today more than
50 years after his death while serving a
prison sentence then named Malcolm
little converted to the Nation of Islam
in 1952 he found mainstream Islam years
later and felt it was much more racially
inclusive in the nation but as Muslim we
will be Muslims I will try and teach the
religion of Islam among the football
Negroes and make them listen
aside from spiritual guidance and the
ability to change your life around
another reason Nasir says I'm
incarcerated people are drawn to the
faith is for another reason entirely how
prisons are organized a central
organizing principle in prison is
containing the threat of violence
inmates are housed and classified
according to the risk of violence they
pose here at Solano it means are housed
dormitory-style
those that pose a higher risk or house
themselves like this with armed guards
in their downtime the crew that inmates
spend time with matters because they're
the ones that also offer protection so
what does any of this have to do with
practicing Islam in prison
well Nasir explains that your brothers
in the faith can actually help protect
you behind bars and that source of
support transcends race Islam does
challenge the strict rules of race in
prison because if a person of another
ethnic group besides African America
comes a Muslim then he's embraced in
Islamic community and he's not only
embraced he's protected from outside
pressures that other groups may place
against them
and being in prison isn't necessarily
that type of situation to where
you know you need to join a group to be
safe
that's not hasn't been my experience but
I would say being a part of a community
in prison is definitely beneficial in
that regard what he is really describing
is support and the support that
incarcerated Muslims require is
different than their free brethren in
fact there are several things about
prison that changed how Islam is
practiced there's no core uh nap no call
to prayer from your cell phone and being
Muslim here is about survival in a
completely different way than it is
outside
it does afford some opportunity for
inmates to think about their
rehabilitation think about meaning in
life think about who they want to be as
a person while here or when leaving here
just because religion might help some
people survive prison doesn't mean
they'll continue the practice after
release
Nasir seen people let go of the faith
when they get out but Hasani who's just
days from release has his sights set on
making Islam's most important journey
for Muslims the pilgrimage we called
Hutch so I think for me that making the
Hajj as as one of my goal primary goals
if I keep that as a primary goal that I
will be successful and not only standing
on the path but doing everything that I
need to do in order to get off the wall
save some money and make the Hajj I
learned so much about incarceration in
this story if you want to learn more
check out ear Hustle the podcast out of
San Quentin prison in the meantime don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
let us know in the comments what prison
stories you want us to cover next